am mittwoch besucht
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
den fliegerhorst gromowski in langen
leben in niederösterreich grund dafür
ein spatenstich am pflege ausbauen
wie diese dokumentation vom fliegerhorst
aus dem jahr 1967 zeigt
der soldat von heute muss ein guter
techniker seien an diesen apparaten
arbeiten hervorragende spezialisten die
für diese instrumenten landung die
verantwortung tragen die erste damals
noch in röhrentechnik
ausgeführte gerade anlage wurde 1992
ersetzt dann und diese anlage auch am
ende ihrer betriebszeit ist muss und
soll einerseits
die neue radaranlage soll ende juli
kommenden jahres den betrieb aufnehmen
rund 5,8 millionen euro werden
investiert ja unglaublich wäre es zu
investieren hier an diesem standard im
gesamten bundesland in den nächsten
beiden jahren über 150 millionen euro
und auf diesem rader turm wird noch
einiges hier an dieser stelle auf damit
es auch in zukunft heißen kann